well you you obviously you alluded to
being fully independent like that can't
be uh everyone's got to be on your line
though I mean maybe not everybody but a
lot of people are banging your line for
sure for sure since the beginning so
what has been the reason why you haven't
tried to go with a label yet I feel like
I haven't reached my full potential yet
well yeah because you're whatever deal
you sign right now they're going to [__]
in some capacity I mean I don't want to
use the word [__] you but for but but
but they they might have the leverage
you could you could put this album out
build up a lot more leverage and then
come back to the table and get a much
better deal probably right that's my
plan yeah definitely that's crazy man
it's wild too cuz man I feel like uh you
know there's been um so many dope La
artists
that I'm going to tell you this be
careful cuzz sometimes I
I've seen this happen
where people will overthink
themselves out of being bigger because
they want to stay independent a little
longer oh I see what you're saying I've
seen this happen and I I mean some of
the bigger La names
ever had a really big record I'm not
talking about recently I'm talking about
let's say the last 10 or 12 years had
opportunities to take deals and like
maybe Elevate things to another level
and we're like nah not yet
so just be careful with that you know
right cuz cuz you never know if the
album comes out and it doesn't do what
you hope it does right then it can hurt
you with talks well I'm nobody notice
but I'm putting my album out through a
Distribution Company oh you're doing Dro
yeah Empire no create oh create shout
out to create creates doing their thing
yeah yeah yeah that's a good see creates
a you want a partner like that you know
what I'm saying somebody who's who give
you some label services but not [__]
exactly yes hell yeah that's the way to
go right there for sure yeah that's
smart so I'm excited to hear what you
guys so is there any remixes being
worked on uh yeah I got a lot of uh I
got a lot of remixes on the way I'm just
I just been saving everything for real
yeah yeah just getting ready like for
the album have you had like like a good
experience with some of the ogs on the
LA side of Hip Hop In terms cuz you
there's no way everyone's in the club
here they all are at [__] uh you know
the clubs they're all they're all
dragonfly they're all at Kingpin Mondays
they're all here in your records so they
know your
[__] has it been a a positive experience
with any of these guys anybody reached
out like you said hey I don't know how I
you know like you mentioned earlier like
310 baby's got five of these he's got
muster blue bucks [__] blue face all
on the remix like right honestly I feel
like uh I've been having good and bad
experiences um I'll say more bad than
good for sure like a lot of people reach
out to me I'm not going to throw no
names out there but [__] will reach
out and be like I'll [__] with what you
doing I'll [__] with your movement let's
do something and that's and I be like
all right come on yeah let's come on hey
I'm in the studio tonight I'm at the
studio right now what you trying to do I
never hear from him again wow ever and
it just kind of make me feel like damn
like is it because I'm only doing
remixes maybe they don't maybe they
don't think the record will get cleared
Maybe that might be it maybe but I got
that side handled though well now they
know yeah we'll see maybe they'll [__]
with me now I N I mean either way though
that's that's that's disingenuine though
like don't reach out to me if like we
can't go get in and cut some [__] bro
I'm really I'm really like from the slum
like I'm from La you feel me so to get
hit up by these people that I looked up
to to big deal it's a big deal to me
like I don't I don't act Hollywood about
it or nothing right I'll take that [__]
to heart when I first uh started blowing
up off of whopp it and tiger DM me I
cried I'm not even going to lie wow I
cried cuz that was my first not cuz it
was Tiger it was just like n but that's
a that was my first time getting uh
getting notoriety from somebody big and
that reaffirms that you're on the right
path exactly I'm talking about this at
the very beginning of January W it blew
up in December I li at my phone I wake
up from a nap with my son I look up
tiger who It remix I'm like what the
[__] I show my mom I started screaming I
couldn't believe it that's so fire cuz
that's a moment that could change
somebody life you feel me no cuz I mean
even if nothing comes from that it's
like well [__] if Tiger saw it and
[__] with it that means I'm on the
right path exactly I'm sure you've had
other DMs like that since then it been a
shitload of them but I'm saying that
that first one like that's what really
got me emotional for real but I'm just
saying like throughout this process and
this path that I've been on I've run
into a lot of situations like that like
people will tap in with me and speak
positive and then I'll never hear from
them what about the guys who you do hear
from who you have had positive
experiences with who are they man shout
out Tai do sign that's like my brother
he's the best yeah I [__] love Tai do
sign I owe him everything he's actually
one of the more like genuine good human
beings I've known him since
2010 11 yeah and uh I mean he just
invited me out to Vegas and uh I was
hanging out with him and his his
daughter and we were chilling with Kanye
all night he literally was like man come
out shout out Kanye and
um I was like the coolest night of my
life to be honest I'm like in a room
with like I mean you know I'm there with
Tai right but I'm Kanye's there and
[__] Legends Tiger's there and Y G's
there and yeah little Dirk was there uh
kid cudy was there oh this the album
[__] they did this was in a [__] at the
at the the Four Seasons in Vegas in
Kanye Suite oh [__] it was they were
finishing the album and then it turned
into like a party and then somehow India
Love started cutting vocal yeah it was
so Rand bro it was and I'm shroomed the
[__]
out I'm like this I can't [__] with
theones bro I was like this [__] is
crazy all right so you say Ty we know Ty
is the greatest shout out to Ty yeah
shout out to Ty and also one of the most
talented human beings to ever do
anything he's a [__] alien legend yes
uh Ty YG for sure definitely [__] with
each other uh whiz whiz is great me and
whiz got a a real good relationship I
love whiz hell yeah [__] just uh a lot
of the up and cominging like La artists
that was on before me like the one te JS
at a ches those like just I love oez man
yeah I [__] with him Me O going to have
a long career man cuz he's a good dude
man definitely me and X4 got a real good
relationship he's great too I I I free
him free x4 I mean cuz we we did a uh
interview and I didn't know what to
expect yeah and he was like the coolest
[__] me you got the real good
sign out of he was so funny and then
like he saw I went uh he saw I went hog
hunting uh in Texas with that Mexican OT
and he dm' me he's like we got to go do
this I was like bro let's go he's like
no for real let's do it I like I'm down
let's go hunting like yeah free x4 free
him man he's he's got he's going to have
a if he can get his [__] together he's
got a bright future most definitely hell
yeah damn yeah you know I want to hear
you on a song blue face though oh yeah
for oh we got a song together do you I
haven't heard it's s a cut though nobody
know about it I want to hear that that's
on the way blue faces again cool dude a
lot of people say what y'all want about
blueface he's mastered he run the
internet though he has mastered the
internet man it's crazy I it's really
like since
69 no one has figured out the internet
better than him I think so yeah in terms
of just like I'm not talking about
anything
and how you feel about 69ine when he was
was hot he had the internet Master
internet on Smash 247 he bro he broke
man I interviewed his baby mama and him
6 months ago and I thought it was a joke
yeah and his lightweight was a joke yeah
it was like baby mama music and she put
out the Stewie song and yeah I told her
to her face her music sucked and
she and she got a deal with Colombia
records oh God in heaven bro I don't
think who else can do that but blue I
don't think they they even believe it
was going to be on that level like when
they first started fuing around but the
Barbie record is hot [__]
crazy and it's like who else could do
that bro that's insane when you this is
his son's this his kid's mom and he was
like you know what I'mma show y'all it
ain't about her it's about me and I'mma
put her on right it's
crazy to blue face man